let's head to Atlanta in Georgia now the
city where Donald Trump was indicted
just a few days ago and it's where his
Rivals for the Republican Presidential
nomination are meeting to Rally support
for their White House campaigns six
hopefuls including Trump's former vice
president Mike Pence and Ron DeSantis
are scheduled to speak oh rawness let's
go to John hendren he's also in Atlanta
first of all John 6 explained was why
Trump is not at this conference
well Trump isn't there for the very
simple reason that he was not invited
the radio host who puts this event on
Eric Erickson doesn't like Trump he says
he Endeavors not to mention his name at
this conference
um and Trump has actually canceled an
event he was going to speak at on Monday
where he said he would offer irrefutable
proof that there was widespread fraud in
Georgia that would exonerate him in the
Georgia case he says he's now been
advised by his lawyers not to do that
not just because he hasn't proved that
point in three years but because his
lawyers want to present those issues in
court so Trump isn't appearing at this
for him he's not appearing on Monday and
at the first Republican debate on
Wednesday in Milwaukee Trump also says
he's probably not going to appear there
so it's conceivable that the first time
we see Trump in public in the next week
is a split screen moment where on
Wednesday the first Republican debate
goes on and if he has surrendered
himself here in Atlanta Anna at the jail
before that time those might be the
first pictures we get of it but he has
also talked about having a competing
event on Wednesday to that Republican
debate so we'll wait and see whether we
see Trump or not but the issue is that
he doesn't have to because he's ahead of
the polls that's why he's not going to
the Wednesday event and all these other
candidates are going to be asked whether
they support the president despite his
legal woes and because he has so much
support in the Republican base he's
about 30 points ahead of the other
candidates in polls
um many of them have been advised to
offer support to Trump and they've been
very few of them have been critical of
them only Chris Christie the governor uh
former governor of New Jersey has been
especially critical so Trump has not
been to the public eye but he also
doesn't think he has to Trump's legal
woes are far-ranging aren't they let's
look at the federal trial connected to
the January 6th riots and his lawyers
have asked for a delay to the start of
that trial
yes believe it or not the prosecutor
Jack Smith has asked for that trial to
start this coming January Trump's
lawyers want to put it off until April
of 2026 that's a year and a half after
the next presidential election and uh by
that time many of these points may be
moot there are a lot of Novel uh legal
issues to be decided but the bottom line
is he really does have a very crowded
legal schedule right now just with the
four criminal indictments he faces uh
the January he he's accused in
Washington DC of uh trying to overturn
the 2020 election that happens in
January the case here in Georgia that
happens in March the New York hush money
case that happens in late March and then
in Florida where he's accused of
mishandling classified documents that
case would start in may the judges are
going to have to decide whether that
works and they're going to have to do
some coordinating because that is also
which I'm When Donald Trump will be
campaigning for president of the United
States where he is by far are the leader
in that race and remember that the U.S
presidential primaries begin at the
beginning of the year the Iowa caucuses
start in January so all that time he's
going to be juggling court and
campaigning and some of those judges may
allow him time to campaign but just to
listen to one of his lawyers he said if
we're to start that case in Washington
D.C in January because there are
millions of documents of discovery that
the government has that have been turned
over to Trump's people he said they
would have to read the equivalent of War
and Peace 78 times every day until
January in order to do that they don't
think that's reasonable so some of these
cases will almost certainly be delayed
well it's certainly going to be an
extraordinary year in U.S politics John
hendren thanks very much for joining us